♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
MARY MALONE:
All right, okay.
(ELECTRONIC HUMMING)
VOICE: (FROM COMPUTER)
Ask a question.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JANE TRANTER:
Angels are creatures of dust.
We discover that
through Mary Malone,
an Oxford scholar.
And is dust dark matter?
VOICE: Yes.
What are you?
VOICE: Angels.
♪ (UPLIFTING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JAMES MCAVOY:
Angels exist across worlds.
A coalescence of dust
into a sentient, active being.
BALTHAMOS:
Don't be afraid.
We're not going to hurt you.
What are you?
BALTHAMOS: Bene elim.
Angels in your language.
Angels?
TRANTER: They have
very human characteristics.
They fall in love.
Balthamos and Baruch
for example,
are a very strong,
romantically linked couple.
The bond between Balthamos
and Baruch is very strong,
and where one goes,
the other feels.
They are sometimes known
as the watchers,
in that they watch over
some worlds.
VOICE: Making.
Stimulating. Guiding.
But why?
VOICE: Vengeance.
TRANTER:
They have long ago,
been thrown out
of the Kingdom of Heaven,
through rebelling against
the rule of the Authority.
XAPHANIA:
We, who fought for truth,
were cast out of the kingdom.
MCAVOY: Xaphania is the leader
of the rebel angels.
She has been leading
the rebel angels for a millennia
and joins forces with me.
The great betrayer.
Wasn't a millennia in exile
not degradation enough for you?
The kingdom as we know it
has already gone, Alarbus.
This is our final rebellion.
MCAVOY:
It's a difficult relationship
because angels and humans
are so far away from each other
in terms of their perspective
on life.
If I have to incarcerate
every angel, I will.
If I have to take a knife
to the heart of the Authority
himself, I will.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
(SHOCKWAVES PULSATING)
(GRIMACING IN PAIN)
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
(WINGS FLUTTERING)
(PAINED GROAN)
(GRUNTING)
I am Lord Asriel Belacqua.
I intend to march upon
the Kingdom of Heaven,
and I should very much
like you to join me.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JAMES MCAVOY:
Asriel is a revolutionary
and freedom fighter.
He finds his allies
and begins building the base
for the rebellion.
Welcome to
the Republic of Heaven,
Commander.
The real war is coming,
and we must win it.
JAMES: Asriel's Republic is
a military encampment
for science, ingenuity,
and his military forces
to gather.
JANE TRANTER: Asriel's council
is made up of Commander Ogunwe,
who looks after
all operational matters.
Ruta Skadi brings
clans of the witches.
Xaphania,
the light angel equivalent
of Metatron's dark angel.
The great betrayer.
You speak of betrayal
when you have taken orders
to kill one of our own kind.
COMMANDER ROKE:
Lord Asriel.
Roke.
JANE: And Commander Roke,
the leader of the Gallivespians
and the whole of
the spy network.
What is it?
A message from
our Magisterium spy,
Agent Salmakia.
She says they're preparing
to undertake a search mission.
-LORD ASRIEL: For what?
-ROKE: Your daughter.
They think she is
the most important child
that's ever lived.
JAMES: Asriel's end goal
is to fight the Authority.
And what he learns
is that it's a slightly
different kind of fight.
What is this?
It's a Gallivespian
communication device.
We have a message from
our agent in the Magisterium.
We're about to land on a remote
island in the German Ocean.
I'll take the intention craft.
It's the fastest way.
Understood.
Try not to die.
(SCOFFS)
♪ (EPIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
Why are you following us?
LADY SALMAKIA: I am a member
of Lord Asriel's republic.
I'm here for you, and the girl,
and your knife.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JANE TRANTER: The Gallivespians
are very, very small creatures
who Asriel uses
as his spy network.
COMMANDER ROKE:
Lord Asriel. Your daughter, sir.
Salmakia believes
she's in danger.
When is Lyra not in danger?
TRANTER: Commander Roke
is the Gallivespian
who sits on Asriel's council.
He has Gallivespians positioned
all over the world
and they communicate with him
and give him information.
Agent Salmakia, for example,
is positioned
in the headquarters
of the Magisterium.
So she can tell Roke
what the Magisterium are up to.
Retrieve the child.
Retrieve the mother.
And return them to me...
dead or alive.
TRANTER: They communicate
using this really strange device
called the lodestone resonator.
Which means that
they can communicate
across the worlds.
Lodestone resonating,
go ahead.
SALMAKIA: We're about to land
on a remote island
in the German Ocean.
Agent Salmakia,
get to the children,
get them to safety,
then stay with them
until I arrive.
-Understood?
-SALMAKIA: Understood.
JAMES MCAVOY:
They're quite prickly.
SALMAKIA: You've been lying
this whole time.
The knife is broken.
LYRA SILVERTONGUE:
Stop attacking him.
SALMAKIA: Give me one reason
why I should.
MCAVOY:
But quite honorable as well.
Because Asriel needs him safe.
Whatever you're doing,
do it quickly.
This war will need us all.
LADY SALMAKIA: We're about to
land on a remote island
in the German Ocean.
Fairisle.
LORD ASRIEL: I know the place.
I'll take the Intention Craft.
♪ (PENSIVE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JANE TRANTER:
The Intention Craft
is a machine that,
through the intent of his mind,
will allow Asriel to journey
through different worlds.
The craft may not be ready
for this.
Well then, that is
on the pair of us, is it not?
(ENGINE WHIRRS)
TRANTER: The force
between himself and his daemon
powers the Intention Craft.
MARISA COULTER:
So your daemon powers it
and your intentions control it,
am I right?
I don't think he'd want you
to be looking at them
quite so forensically.
TRANTER: Mrs. Coulter looks over
some plans for it,
and we see her exploring it
before Asriel arrives.
And then we just see her
having the sort of pluckiness
to get in it
and just give it a go.
Marisa!
Goodbye, Asriel.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪